i was a competitive gymnast both of my
parents are very fit
i have exercised since i was
a kid and i i will always do it it's so
important to me i just it's funny
because i'm taking a um
anatomy
physical fitness class at school right
now i actually just got my final exam
before i got a physical fitness class
yeah so it's a health class
right study it's basically for people i
think who are interested in getting into
like
kinesiology or
personal training or that kind of stuff
but i just took it because i'm
interested so i've been like building
fake exercise programs for
for people um for fake hypothetical
people and do one for me
you want me to create a program for you
yeah but yeah that would be great you
already work out i mean i don't work out
very much
probably a couple times
mostly michael you just need to
make sure that your cardiovascular
health is really good i don't do a lot
of cardio i have to 150 minutes of
moderate to visible moderate to vigorous
physical activity per week
150 what
minutes
it's not that much
two and a half hours is what that is
two and a half hours so you can go walk
really fast for a while you can go for a
jog you can just make sure that your
heart rate is up at a decent rate
jeez ryan do you do that i was trying to
calculate i don't think so
you do that kristen what do you do
what do you do fair amount
no i mean are you on a treadmill or do
you go for a run i like running outside
you're like right now i started drinking
the pandemic i hated running i hated
cardio right yeah with my back so it's
the impact so i can't really do that but
i can go on brisk walks
i could uh you know
i could bike if i want to but i'm on it
is it your back yeah it's just like it's
not great for your back when the impact
is swimming
i i do i am a member of a little club
that has a pool swimming would be
perfect if you could get in
some swimming is something that you
liked or like um
150 minutes like a stationary bicycle i
have one i just haven't used it
but for your back do is it like an
upgrade are you okay in an upright
bicycle or are you better
upright's fine i mean both are fine yeah
i think i should do that
you only have to do it like five times a
week for 30 minutes you're really uh
intense about this 150 minutes a week
like there's something that you've read
in this book of uh
physiology uh what is it
yeah i think that the the research
suggests that you get a huge boost in
benefit health benefits at 150
minutes per week maybe my anxiety will
go down if i just uh we work hard it
will help your anxiety really
yeah and you need to do two days of
resistance training which i think you
already do resistance like weights
do you have a trainer you just do it by
yourself
no i have an all women's gym that i go
to right now in in toronto and it's like
all it's like fun because it's it's all
barbell strength training so we get to
lift heavy and i like doing that don't
you like going to an all women's gym so
you don't have to have guys hit on you
and stare at you
yeah i i do
but but i don't know i don't know if
that would happen as much any anymore
what do you mean anymore
men are maturing
no
men are
tend to gravitate towards
younger women
when they go to his oh
kristen you don't look your age i'm not
saying i'm not saying i'm just making a
comment okay
like
15 years old is when i got hit on the
most
five 15 men oh yeah oh
god
that's gross i'm sorry you had to deal
with that [ __ ]